light is the fastest thing we know it's
so fast that we measure enormous
distances by how long it takes for light
to travel them in one year light travels
about six trillion miles a distance we
call one light year to give you an idea
of just how far this is the moon which
took the Apollo astronauts four days to
reach is only one light second from
Earth
meanwhile the nearest star beyond our
own Sun is Proxima Centauri 4.2 four
light years away our Milky Way is on the
order of a hundred thousand light years
across the nearest galaxy to our own
Andromeda is about 2.5 million light
years away space is mind-blowingly vast
but wait how do we know how far away
stars and galaxies are after all when we
look at the sky we have a flat
two-dimensional view if you point your
finger to one star you can't tell how
far this star is so how do
astrophysicists figure that out for
objects that are very close by we can
use a concept called trigonometric
parallax the idea is pretty simple let's
do an experiment stick out your thumb
and close your left eye now open your
left eye and close your right eye it
will look like your thumb has moved
while more distant background objects
have remained in place the same concept
applies when we look at the Stars but
distant stars are much much farther away
than the length of your arm and the
earth isn't very large so even if you
had different telescopes across the
equator you'd not see much of a shift in
position instead we look at the change
in the star's apparent location over six
months the halfway point of the Earth's
year-long orbit around the Sun when we
measure the relative positions of the
stars in summer and then again in winter
it's like looking with your other eye
nearby stars seem to have moved against
the background of the more distant stars
and galaxies but this method only works
for objects no more than a few thousand
light years away beyond our own galaxy
the distances are so great that the
parallax is too small to detect
even our most sensitive instruments so
at this point we have to rely on a
different method using indicators we
call standard candles standard candles
are objects whose intrinsic brightness
or luminosity we know really well for
example if you know how bright your
light bulb is and you ask your friend to
hold the light bulb and walk away from
you you know that the amount of light
you receive from your friend will
decrease by the distance squared so by
comparing the amount of light you
receive to the intrinsic brightness of
the light bulb you can then tell how far
away your friend is in astronomy our
light bulb turns out to be a special
type of star called a Cepheid variable
these stars are internally unstable like
a constantly inflating and deflating
balloon and because the expansion and
contraction causes their brightness to
vary we can calculate their luminosity
by measuring the period of this cycle
with more luminous stars changing more
slowly
by comparing the light we observed from
these stars to the intrinsic brightness
we've calculated this way we can tell
how far away they are unfortunately this
is still not the end of the story we can
only observe individual stars up to
about 40 million light years away after
which they become too blurry to resolve
but luckily we have another type of
standard candle the famous type 1a
supernova supernova giant stellar
explosions are one of the ways that
stars die these explosions are so bright
that they outshine the galaxies where
they occur so even when we can't see
individual stars in a galaxy we can
still see supernovae when they happen
and type 1a supernovae turn out to be
usable as standard candles because
intrinsically bright ones fade slower
than fainter ones through our
understanding of this relationship
between brightness and decline rate we
can use these supernovae to probe
distances up to several billions of
light-years away but why is it important
to see such distant objects anyway well
remember how fast light travels for
example the light emitted by the Sun
will take eight minutes to reach us
which means that the light we see now is
a picture of the Sun eight minutes ago
when you look at the Big Dipper you're
seeing what it looked like 80 years ago
and those smudgy galaxies there are
millions of light years away
it has taken millions of years for that
light to reach us so the universe itself
is in some sense an inbuild time machine
the further we can look back the younger
the universe we are probing
astrophysicists try to read the history
of the universe and understand how and
where we come from the universe is
constantly sending us information in the
form of light all that remains is for us
to decode it